[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend in allen und RF Torf Israel
wo sie heute einen runden Geburtstag
feiern 75 Jahre Staatsgründung ein
Dreivierteljahrhundert in dem die
Menschen in Israel viel erlebt haben und
viel gemeistert es sind viel weniger als
etwa in Bayern flächenmäßig ist das Land
gerade mal so groß wie Hessen ein einst
bitterarmer Agrarstaat der zur Hightech
Boom-Region wurde der Kriege und
Konflikte er lebte und überlebte und
immer noch und immer wieder erlebt weil
elementare Fragen ungelöst sind das
Verhältnis zu den Palästinensern zu den
Nachbarn und ganz aktuell das Verhältnis
der Israelis untereinander
und so hat heute ein Staat Geburtstag in
dem hunderttausende seit Monaten auf die
Straße gehen weil sie sorgen haben dass
er so wie Sie ihn kennen und mögen in
größter Gefahr ist und zwar von innen
Michael Beverungen ist unser
Korrespondent in Israel
Militärflieger bei Israel gehören zu
jedem Unabhängigkeitstag dazu sie
demonstrieren wie weit es Israel
gebracht hat viele befreundete Nationen
fliegen mit dieses Jahr zum ersten Mal
auch ein deutscher Kampfjet
zugleich ist die Flugshow eine
Demonstration der Stärke seht her das
Land das jeden Konflikt beherrscht
dass das weder im äußeren noch im
Inneren so richtig funktioniert
interessiert die Israelis heute weniger
der Streit um die Justizreform und die
Tiefe Spaltung der Nation die meisten
wollen das gerne mal für einen Tag
vergessen stattdessen grillen und
chillen mit der ganzen Familie es gibt
Probleme aber die sind lösbar heute
sollten wir uns nicht darauf
konzentrieren wir haben das ganze Jahr
dafür nicht am Feiertag
auch Arielle Oster sieht sich die
Flugshow an in Gedanken aber wird er ins
Tel Aviv von 1948 zurückkehren als für
Juden auf der ganzen Welt ein Traum wahr
wurde da wartete der damals Zwölfjährige
Arielle vor dem Haus in dem bengorion
den Staat Israel ausrief
es war als bekämen wir ein großes großes
Geschenk etwas das wir uns die ganze
Zeit schon gewünscht hatten und als wir
davon im Radio hörten verließen die
Leute spontan ihre Häuser schnappten
sich Autos oder Busse und kamen hierher
und da fingen wir an zu tanzen
dass der Traum von damals heute in
Gefahr ist macht ihm sorgen
heute gibt es eine Menge Streit das Land
ist in zwei Teile gespalten linke gegen
Rechte aber um weiter existieren zu
können müssen wir zu einer Einigung
kommen
beim Beginn der feiern gestern Abend war
wenig davon zu spüren dass sich Israel
in der schwersten innenpolitischen Krise
seit der Staatsgründung befindet
Benjamin netanjau der mit seiner Politik
die Gesellschaft polarisiert
ausgerechnet er ruft per Videobotschaft
zur Einheit auf Jonas lassen Sie uns den
ganzen Aufruhr stoppen lassen Sie uns
für einen Moment das große Wunder das
Israel heißt bestaunen
schöne Bilder die an der Realität
Vorbeigehen auch gestern demonstrierten
Zehntausende gegen die sogenannte
Justizreform und heute zumindest
symbolischer Protest am Strand ein
Artefakt der Unabhängigkeitserklärung
als Mahnung
doch wie konnten die Staatsgründer in
dieser Erklärung die Checks und balances
vergessen eine zweite Kammer etwa oder
eine geschriebene Verfassung und das
wurde historischen Erfahrung dass die
Nationalsozialisten die Demokratie
demokratisch abgeschafft hatten
die Zionisten von damals dachten sie
wären auf irgendeine Weise immun dagegen
wir haben diese Lektion so gut gelernt
dachten sie wir waren die Opfer wie um
Himmels willen könnte es auch nur
denkbar sein dass wir den gleichen
Fehler begehen aber das ist natürlich
eine Fantasie
wir sind alle Menschen und alle
fehlerhaft
die Gefahr für Israels Demokratie blieb
heute im Hintergrund doch es ist nur ein
Tag Pause im Kampf um die Zukunft des
Landes
75 Jahre mit Rutz paar und balagan also
Dreistigkeit und durcheinander worauf
sie sehr stolz sind in Israel moses hat
uns 40 Jahre lang durch die Wüste
geschleppt um uns an den einzigen Ort im
Nahen Osten zu bringen an dem es kein Öl
gibt hatte sich goldame Ehrenmal beklagt
die erste und bislang einzige
Regierungschefin des Landes so gesehen
ist das alles ein Wunder Christian von
Rechenberg
[Musik]
das Israel ein besonderer Staat ist
sieht man an seinen Grenzen wer das Land
einmal umrundet den begleiten Zäune
Mauern sperren und Patienen durchgehend
Bedrohung und Abschottung als
Dauerzustand israel hat viele Kriege um
seine Grenzen geführt und führen müssen
durch Friedensverträge abgesichert sind
nur die Grenzen zu Jordanien und zu
Ägypten dazu kommt der umstrittene
Status des Westjordanlandes israel hält
es seit fast 56 Jahren besetzt 700.000
Israelis siedeln dort nach
internationalem Recht
illegal
über Land erreichbar ist Israel im
Norden praktisch gar nicht einzig die UN
kommt hierdurch in diplomatischer
Mission und so wirkt Israel
eingeschlossen und noch kleiner das
Kernland 22.000 Quadratkilometer groß
nur etwas größer als Hessen hier leben
rund 10 Millionen Menschen ohne eine
geschriebene Verfassung noch so eine
Besonderheit solide abgesichert ist die
Demokratie Israels nicht
übrigens nach gregorianischen Kalender
riefen die Gründer den Staat Israel am
14 Mai aus gefeiert wird aber nach
jüdischem Kalender daher heute
Simon Stein war offizieller Vertreter
des Staates Israel hier bei uns in
Deutschland als Botschafter seines
Landes erwirtschafter guten Abend
guten Abend der Liebe Sievers
ausgerechnet zum runden Geburtstag es
Israel jetzt ein mehr denn je tief
gespaltenes Land wie konnte das
passieren
wie konnte das passieren
eigentlich durch ein Schicksal einer
Person die ja um allen zu tun um sein
politisches Überleben und das Land
mitgenommen auf ein Abenteuer dessen
Ende noch nicht abzusehen ist das ist
eigentlich der Hauptgrund weshalb wir
heute sind wo sie sind das ist ja nicht
zu sagen dass alle Probleme die ja jetzt
zum Vorschein gekommen sind sind neu
aber wir haben es verstanden mit der
tiefen Spaltung die sie aus ihre Zeit in
Israel auch kennen weiter zu leben war
ist das die äußere Gefahr diese
Gesellschaft zusammengeführt hat aber
die tiefgreifende
Probleme die uns seit der Entstehung des
Staates begleiten
zum großen Teil nicht gelöst sind aber
wir haben den Kompromiss gefunden mit
dem wir 75 Jahren relativ gut gefahren
sind und diese eine Person die sie da
ansprechen nämlich an ist natürlich der
Regierungschef Benjamin Netanjahu wir
erleben im Moment ja außerordentliches
wir erleben ehemalige Chefs des
Auslandsgeheimdienstes die offene tanjao
kritisieren wir erleben Armeechefs die
dasselbe tun auch der diplomatische
Dienst ihr diplomatischer Dienst Herr
Botschafter hat gestreikt bereits gegen
netanjaho wie hat man sich das aktuell
vorzustellen fällt es jetzt auch gerade
manchen ihrer Kollegen schwer diese
Regierung noch zu vertreten
ja um was handelte sich das ist auch
unter den Diplomaten
Meinungsunterschiede über politische
Entscheidungen über Fragen die uns
begleiten wir dir die palästinensische
Problematik oder die Siedlungen das sind
alle Probleme mit denen wir als
Diplomaten umgehen können aber was jetzt
auf der Tagesordnung steht ist den
Charakter dieses Landes denn diese
Regierung hat vor dieses Land umzubauen
das ist ja nicht nur ein Justizreform
die er vor hat sondern den ganzen Stadt
umzubauen so dass am Ende könnte eine
Diktatur entstehen und deshalb glaube
ich ist Israel am 75 Geburtstag an einem
historischen kritischen
existenziellen Scheide weg und hier
glaube ich kann man kann Kompromiss
angehen entweder sind wir an der
liberale Demokratie mit einer
Gewaltenteilung mit einer
Rechtsstaatlichkeit mit einer
Pressefreiheit mit Gleichberechtigung
für alle und das sind wir nicht und
deshalb gibt es momentan keine
Möglichkeit Kompromisse einzugehen jetzt
hat aber wenn ihr militan Yahoo muss man
ja sagen eine Mehrheit mit seiner
Koalition im Parlament in der Knesset
heißt das dass die Mehrheit der Israelis
mit diesem Umbau eigentlich
einverstanden ist eben die die nicht auf
die Straße gehen
eine interessante Frage denn ich
verstehe dass die Demonstranten kommen
ja nicht nur auf dem sogenannten linken
Lage oder aus der Mitte sondern sie
werden auch dort zahlreiche Liquid
Parteifreunde von netanjau und religiöse
die mit diesen vorhanden überhaupt nicht
einverstanden sind so dass wie gesagt
das ist eine Frage die über die
Tagespolitik hinausgeht weil die
Menschen verstehen warum es sich geht um
den Charakter diese Stadt ist und das
muss bewahrt wenn er jene seit der
politischen Unterschiede es ist ja nicht
um von ungefähr dass die palästinesische
Frage keine Rolle bei den
Demonstrationen spielt in dem Moment in
dem diese Frage wird dann besetzt werden
dann wird es doch eine Spaltung
innerhalb der Demonstranten
deshalb müssen wir uns auf das
gemeinsame jetzt verständigen und das
ist den demokratischen Charakter dieses
Landes auf frech zu erhalten Herr
Botschaft damit der bitte um kurze
Antwort noch der deutsche
Bundespräsident hat sich beunruhigt
gezeigt über den geplanten Umbau des
Rechtsstaates jetzt hat ihr nach
Nachfolger der aktuelle israelische
Botschafter in Berlin gesagt er
verbittet sich eigentlich Appelle und
erhobene Zeigefinger heißt denn das gute
Freunde also sprich wir in Deutschland
sollten lieber still sein bei der Sache
darum gar nicht
Deutschland ist generell zurückhaltend
aber das ist der eine Zeit wo Freunde
Flagge zeigen mussten und Israel darauf
hinweisen das was uns unter anderem
einigt ist eine Wertegemeinschaft und
deshalb wenn man besorgen ist zum
Ausdruck bringt findest da finde ich das
korrekt auch wenn es von einer deutsche
Seite kommt JOM hat's mal utzer mehr
sagen sich heute alle in Israel der
Botschafter herzlichen Dank für das
Gespräch heute Abend live aus München
war das im ZDF heute journal
unser nächstes Thema die Zahlen sind
klar im vergangenen Jahr haben fast
218.000 Menschen in Deutschland erstmals
einen Antrag auf Asyl gestellt dazu
kommen rund eine Million
Kriegsflüchtlinge aus der Ukraine die
keinen Antrag stellen mussten in diesem
Jahr dürfte die Zahl der neuen
Asylbewerber noch mal steigen von den
Interessenverbänden der Kommunen in
Deutschland kommt ein Hilferuf nach dem
anderen es geht um mehr als
Unterbringung es geht um konkrete
Zusagen beim Thema Integration es geht
um viel bei der Konferenz der
zuständigen Landesministerinnen und
Minister heute
Susanna Santina zeigt die Lage
eine indoorspielhalle im hessischen
Groß-Rohrheim umfunktioniert zum
Wohnraum für ukrainische geflüchtete
Großzelt in Bensheim vor allem für
geflüchtete aus Syrien Afghanistan und
der Türkei und in Erlensee ziehen ab
morgen in diese containerwohnungen 160
Flüchtlinge aus Syrien und Afghanistan
ein in Main-Kinzig-Kreis ist es
mittlerweile die 15
Gemeinschaftsunterkunft das sei
notwendig sagt Landrat Thorsten stolz
allein im Dezember wurden täglich 160
geflüchtete zugewiesen es ist eine
riesen Kraftanstrengung immer ein
kindskreis hat etwas über 420.000
Einwohnerinnen und Einwohner und wir
haben im vergangenen Jahr ungefähr
9.200 Menschen als geflüchtete als
Asylsuchende hier bei uns in den 29
Städten und Gemeinden untergebracht und
einfach auch versorgt wirklich glücklich
ist man über diese Unterkünfte mitten im
Gewerbegebiet von Erlensee nicht
und auch diese Container Unterkunft ist
im Prinzip aus der Not heraus geboren
eigentlich um ihn zu integrieren müsste
man Menschen in Wohnraum unterbringen
und zwar in eigenen Wohnraum mit
Nachbarn mit einer Community drumherum
mit Vereinsleben also genau das
Gegenteil von dem was wir hier
eigentlich tun im Kreis Bergstraße hat
man für die Flüchtlinge alleine im
letzten Jahr 19 Millionen Euro
investiert es geben seither deutlich
mehr als in der flüchtlingskrise 2015/16
sagen Landrat Christian Engelhardt und
sein Kreis Beigeordneter von den Grünen
das Hauptproblem ist es schlichtweg die
Menge und ein ganzer Teil davon kommt
ohne Bleibeperspektive und bleibt
trotzdem da und nimmt uns damit die
Ressourcen und um die Menschen zu
kümmern um tatsächlich Bleibeperspektive
haben dass wir natürlich auch durch
unsere fehlenden Ressourcen nicht jedem
ein integrationsangebot so machen können
wie sich gehört also relativ schnell in
Sprachkurse von Bam bringen dass wir
schnelle Unterkünfte finden dass wir im
Grunde ist ja auch sozialpädagogisch gut
betreuen können das gelingt dann nicht
mehr
ein wichtiges Mittel der Integration ist
auch geflüchtete Kinder schnell in
Kindergärten zu bringen jeder Platz
kostet die Gemeinde rund 4000 Euro
in Bensheim waren diese Zelte als
provisorische Unterkunft gedacht
mittlerweile leben die geflüchteten aus
Syrien der Türkei und Afghanistan schon
seit Monaten hier der Frust bei vielen
ist groß
wenn ihr kein Platz aufgenommen
ich bin seit zwei Monaten hier aber
viele schon seit sechs bis acht Monaten
das ist ein großes Problem
und ich verstehe nicht warum einige
schneller wegkommen und wir nicht
monatelang in solchen Unterkünften an
integration ist bei vielen Kommunen
derzeit nicht zu denken vorrangig geht
es darum Wohnraum zu schaffen allein das
sei eine riesen Herausforderung
wir bleiben noch in der Politik eins ist
klar mehr als 30 Stunden wie beim
letzten Mal soll es diesmal nicht dauern
wenn sich heute Abend die Spitzen der
Regierungskoalition wieder
zusammensetzen allerdings kann man da
wirklich so sicher sein
also ausschließen möchte man ja bei der
angespannten Grundstimmung in der Ampel
momentan gar nichts aber klar ist dass
die Ampel zurzeit kein Interesse daran
hat noch mal neue sitzungsrekorde
aufzustellen und damit auch öffentlich
quasi vorzuführen wie groß die
Differenzen bei einigen Themen sind alle
Beteiligten haben da heute ordentlich
vorgebaut indem sie nämlich gesagt haben
es gibt keine Tagesordnung und das soll
auch keine Beschlüsse geben das heißt
man kann drängende Themen wie zum
Beispiel die Wohnungsnot oder auch
Migrationspolitik ansprechen ohne sich
bis ins letzte Detail verhaken zu müssen
das war beim letzten Mal anders bei
dieser großen Mammutsitzung da sollten
konkrete Ergebnisse her um eben einige
zentrale Reformprojekte noch vor der
Sommerpause anzuschieben und in
Gesetzesform zu gießen und da zeigte
sich dann eben wo die Gräben liegen und
wie schwierig es ist sich im Detail zu
einigen zwischen
fdp-grünen und SPD das soll diesmal
vermieden werden jetzt haben wir aber
schon erlebt dass selbst Punkte die
eigentlich geklärt sein sollten
plötzlich dann doch wieder strittig
scheinen Beispiel heizungsgesetz zum
Beispiel wird das heute abend noch mal
neu und dann vielleicht endgültig
angepackt da konnte man tatsächlich
heute den Eindruck bekommen und auch in
den letzten Tagen weil es eben vermehrt
Stimmen aus den ampelparteien gab die
das ganze noch mal in Frage gestellt
haben der Justizminister der von der FDP
hat noch einmal gesagt man müsste sich
noch mal gucken anschauen ob der Entwurf
überhaupt verfassungsmäßig sei der
FDP-Generalsekretär nannte die von
Habeck geplante heizungswände hasst dich
und kompliziert und von SPD und Grünen
hörte man noch mal Änderungswünsche bei
der finanziellen Unterstützung
Heizungstausch vor allem für für ärmere
Menschen also da ist noch eine Menge
Konflikt Konfliktstoff drin allerdings
auch nicht für diese Sitzung heute denn
momentan spielt das Ganze im Bundestag
im Parlament wo es verhandelt wird das
heißt also auch da muss man sich heute
Abend nicht verhaken vielen Dank für
diese aktuellen Informationen und einem
weiteren
koalitionsausschussabend in Berlin noch
sitzen sie die weiteren wichtigen
Nachrichten und jetzt im Überblick und
die hast du Hanna und dann blicken wir
zunächst auf eine Entscheidung des
Bundesamts für Verfassungsschutz dass
die Jugendorganisation der AFD nun als
gesichert rechtsextremistisch eingestuft
hat die Positionen der jungen
alternative seien mit dem Grundgesetz
nicht vereinbar erklärter
Verfassungsschutz Präsident halten
Wangen die neue Einstufung hat zur Folge
dass die Hürde für den
einsatznachrichtendienstlicher Mittel
nur niedriger liegt als zuvor auch das
sogenannte Institut für Staatspolitik
und der Verein ein Prozent wurden als
rechtsextrem eingestuft alle drei
Gruppierungen waren zuvor als
Verdachtsfall beobachtet worden
die Beschaffung von Ausrüstung bei der
Bundeswehr soll deutlich beschleunigt
werden das will Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius mit mehreren erlassen
erreichen die umgehend in Kraft treten
der Faktor Zeit sei Priorität 1 sagte
Pistorius zudem soll künftig auf
Sonderanfertigungen verzichtet und
gekauft werden was am Markt verfügbar
ist komplizierte Vorschriften sollen
vereinfacht werden zudem können
Beschaffungsentscheidungen in Zukunft
auch ohne Spitzen Ebene gefällt werden
erstmals seit Beginn des russischen
angriffskriegs auf die Ukraine haben der
chinesische Präsident Chi und der
ukrainische Präsident selenski ein
Telefonat geführt selenski erklärte es
sei ein langes und bedeutsames Gespräch
gewesen sie kündigte im Anschluss an
einen Sondergesandten in die Region zu
schicken um über eine politische Lösung
zu sprechen
der Bundestag hat dem
evakuierungseinsatz der Bundeswehr im
Sudan nachträglich zugestimmt mit keiner
einzigen nein Stimme und nur sieben
Enthaltungen in den frühen Morgenstunden
wurde die Mission vorerst beendet wegen
der akuten Gefährdungslage wurden seit
Sonntag mehr als 700 Menschen
ausgeflogen trotz der noch geltenden
Waffenruhe werden vor allem aus der
Hauptstadt cartoon Kämpfe gemeldet
Rentnerinnen und Renten an Deutschland
dürfen sich über ein deutliches Plus bei
ihren Altersbezügen freuen im besten
werden die Renten zum ersten Juli um
4,39% angehoben im Osten sind es 5,86
Prozent das hat das Bundeskabinett
beschlossen damit liegt die Rente im
Osten und im Westen dann auf gleichem
Niveau ein Jahr eher als ursprünglich
geplant
das Oberste Gericht in Iran hat das
Todesurteil gegen den Deutsch Iraner
jumpshit charmat bestätigt
Außenministerin bärburg bezeichnete dies
daraufhin als inakzeptabel und forderte
Iran auf das Zitat willkürliche Urteil
unverzüglich rückgängig zu machen der
68-Jährige schamat war im Februar ein
Teheran wegen terrorvorwürfen zum Tode
verurteilt worden zudem wird er der
Spionage beschuldigt
für die Hersteller von Wärmepumpen ist
die Bundesregierung insbesondere in
Gestalt von Minister Robert Habeck ja so
etwas wie der personifizierte
Konjunkturmotor die geforderte und
geförderte Wände in den deutschen
Heizungskellern beschert der Branche
knallvolle Auftragsbücher und Dollar
Augen letztere im wahrsten Sinne denn
der klassische deutsche Mittelständler
Viessmann verkauft jetzt seine
wärmepumpensparte an einen Industrie
Riesen aus den USA für sehr viele
Dollars profitiert also von all den
deutschen fördern am Ende kräftig das
Ausland und was heißt das für den Markt
und damit letztlich auch für alle die
eine Wärmepumpe brauchen werden
Antworten heute Abend von Oliver
Heuchert und Christoph Wiesel
der Kanzler selbst schraubte bei
Viessmann vergangenen Sommer an einer
Wärmepumpe damit wollte Scholz deutlich
machen wie wichtig die
Wärmepumpentechnik für Deutschland ist
es geht um Hightech modernste
Technologien die uns in die Lage
versetzen sollen
damit zu gewinnen unser Klima zu
schützen und das zu tun ohne den
Rückgriff auf die bisherigen fossilen
Ressourcen das ist ein wichtiges
Vorhaben der jetzigen Bundesregierung
nun aber wird der größte Teil von
Viessmann auch die wärmepumpenproduktion
an den US-amerikanischen Hersteller von
Klimaanlagen Carrier global verkauft für
satte 12 Milliarden Euro ein hoher Preis
für einen Unternehmensteil der dieses
Jahr rund 4 Milliarden Euro Umsatz
erwartet und rund 700 Millionen Euro
gewinnen die Optionen haben wir sehr
hart gegeneinander abgewogen wir haben
für uns festgestellt dass wir einfach so
weitermachen emotional bevorzugen würden
weil es für uns eine
absolute emotionale Heimat ist in der
wir uns bewegen wir sind eine große
Familie im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
wenn man bei festgestellt dass das
langfristig nicht reichen wird nach 106
Jahren Firmengeschichte traut sich die
Familie Viessmann nicht mehr zu
eigenständig weiter zu arbeiten
anders der Wärmepumpenhersteller STIEBEL
ELTRON in Holzminden fast 100 Jahre alt
steht hier bis auf weiteres kein Verkauf
an aber auch bei STIEBEL ELTRON plant
man sehr große Investitionen es geht
jetzt darum mit dem Markt zu wachsen
schnell mit dem Markt zu wachsen und gut
mit dem Markt zu wachsen wie man das
finanziert ja die Final die die die
Investitionen sind erheblich die man
tätigen muss im Hause STIEBEL ELTRON
werden wir bis
2027 nach unserer eigenen
Mittelfristplanung knappe 700 Millionen
Euro investieren müssen eine weitere
Belastung Klimaanlagen und Wärmepumpen
sind ähnliche Geräte in Asien
millionenfach hergestellt deren
Hersteller kommen jetzt auf den
europäischen Markt und bedrängen alle
deutschen Hersteller laut Klima und
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck führt
das und auch der Viessmann verkauft zu
geringeren Preisen
die Beteiligung von Carrier global bei
Viessmann wird auch dazu führen dass die
Wärmepumpen des Hauses Viessmann
günstiger werden denn der ganze Sinn der
Operation ist ja mehr zu produzieren das
Ministerium prüft den Verkauf jetzt habe
ich selbst denkt aber nicht das ist
Einwände gibt
in Sachen Arbeitsplätze bei Viessmann
wurde vereinbart der Standort im
nordhessischen Allendorf bleibt für
mindestens zehn Jahre erhalten für die
kommenden drei Jahre sind
betriebsbedingte Kündigungen
ausgeschlossen
es geht um viel Geld auch im nächsten
Thema wie viele Schulden dürfen die
einzelnen EU-Staaten machen bislang gab
es da strenge starre Regeln für alle
gleich auf dem Papier
und dann gab es die Realität und da
wurden diese Regeln reihenweise
gebrochen auch von Deutschland die EU
hat blaue Briefe verschickt und das
war's
so geht's nicht weiter darauf können
sich noch alle einigen was stattdessen
stehen soll in den neuen europäischen
Schuldenregeln da liegen die Ansichten
weit auseinander genauso weit wie die
Verschuldung der jeweiligen einzelnen
EU-Staaten
im Reformvorschlag aus Brüssel hat der
Rum gestrichen Theo Waigel wurde gerade
84 und hat noch Anmerkungen zur
Tagespolitik und der Helmut Kohl war er
der Finanzminister er gab dem Euro den
Namen und er gab ihm
1997 in Dublin mit 14 anderen Ministern
auch die Regel
klar ist eine gemeinsame Währung
souveräner Staaten lebt vom Vertrauen
und das Vertrauen in eine
Vertragsgemeinschaft kann nur erreicht
und gewährleistet werden wenn es klare
Regeln für alle gibt den stabilitäts-
und Wachstumspakt wollen sie ändern am
Mittag machen zwei EU-Kommissare einen
Vorschlag und stehen dabei nicht nur bei
Weigel und der Verdacht zu locker zu
uneinheitlich
wir leben in einer ganz anderen Welt als
vor 30 Jahren andere Probleme andere
Prioritäten
die EU will klimaneutral werden also
ihre Wirtschaft grün umbauen sie will
souverän werden also ihre Armeen besser
ausstatten das braucht Investitionen
aber der packt so wie er ist hilft nicht
schauen Sie auf die Schulden die steigen
schauen Sie auf die Investitionen die
sind
der Vorschlag heute beantwortet beide
Aspekte nebenbei wir nennen ihn
stabilitäts- und Wachstumspakt
der setzte immer Grenzen für die
Neuverschuldung drei Prozent der
Wirtschaftskraft für den Schuldenstand
60%. dabei bleibt es aber Euro-Staaten
haben für den Schuldenabbau künftig vier
Jahre Zeit wenn die Neuverschuldung dann
noch bei 3% oder höher liegt greift eine
einsparvorgabe ein halbes Prozent runter
jedes Jahr die Reform versucht eine
Balance zu finden zwischen Schuldenabbau
auf der einen Seite und wichtigen
Zukunftsinvestitionen auf der anderen
Seite und das Regelwerk versucht das so
zu lösen dass Länder einen länger
gestreckten Schuldenabbau erzielen
können wenn sie in diese Klima und
digital und
verteidigungsinvestitionen geld
investieren doch der amtierende deutsche
Finanzminister wollte härtere
Einsparvorgaben die Balance Stimme nicht
eine Missverständnis hingeben dass die
Zustimmung der Bundesregierung
automatisch gesichert ist wir stimmen
nur Regeln zu die wirklich einen
verlässlichen Pfad zu geringeren
Schulden und stabilen Staatsfinanzen
dann auch bringen werden da würde Theo
Waigel seinen sechsten Nachfolger gern
bestärken Änderungen durchsetzen bevor
der Text aus Brüssel Gesetz ist
wir bleiben noch beim Geld und gucken
nach vorne mit Johanna denn die
Bundesregierung hat ihre
Konjunkturprognose für das laufende Jahr
nach oben korrigiert und geht nun von
einem Wirtschaftswachstum von
0,4% aus fragen wir nach bei Valerie
Haller in Frankfurt wie begründet
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck diese
Anhebung ja er macht das an einigen
Fakten fest
industrieproduktionen Auftragseingänge
und Geschäftsklima entwickeln sich
positiv eine energiepreiskrise ist
ausgeblieben ja und habe gelobt auch die
Wirtschaft sie haben sich als
anpassungs-
2,7% im nächsten Treiber sein vor allem
die Nahrungsmittelpreise insgesamt ist
die Bundesregierung mit Blick auf die
Konjunktur etwas optimistischer als die
führenden Wirtschaftsforscher und auch
als einige Wirtschaftsverbände die Sagen
von einer nachhaltigen Erholung ist
Deutschland noch weit entfernt Schuld
daran auch der Fachkräftemangel und die
hohen Strompreise beide Themen will die
Regierung in den kommenden Monaten
angehen und wenn es klappt wäre das für
den Standort Deutschland sicher ein
großer Gewinn vielen Dank Valerie nach
Frankfurt
und es fehlt noch der Blick auf die
Lottozahlen an diesen Mittwoch die
lauten 1 3 18 25 41 49 Superzahl 7 alle
Angaben wie immer ohne Gewähr
das war es von uns wir haben jetzt noch
zwei Hinweise für Sie zwei wichtige ja
der erste das heute journal Update gegen
0:30 Uhr und noch einer nämlich davor
vor dem Update jetzt gleich nach uns
Kulturkampf im Sunshine State warum in
Florida so viele Bücher in Schulen
verboten werden und was dort plötzlich
alles als pornografisch gilt das gleich
im auslandsjournal in allen ein
angenehmer
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter noch ist es
relativ kühl bei uns aber es kommt mild
aus dem Südwesten ja und das ist kein
Vergleich dazu was in Spanien passiert
hier eine Hitzewelle mit 35 bis teils an
die 40 Grad das wird in den nächsten
Tagen erwartet und das nach der Dürre
der letzten Wochen und Monate und da
kommt auch wenig Regen hin sehen ist ja
fast überall in Europa regnet es mal
aber im Süden Spaniens da kommt nichts
runter schauen wir auf die Nacht und da
gibt's im Nordwesten Deutschlands etwas
Regen und auch ganz im Süden dazwischen
da bildet sich durchaus Nebelwald
Temperaturen bis minus drei Grad im
Westen und fünf Grad im Südosten
Deutschlands morgen dann im Süden noch
einzelne Schauer die verabschieden sich
allmählich neue Schauer kommen von
Nordwesten rein dazwischen ist es
durchaus aufgelockert mit viel Sonne das
bei Höch diesen Temperaturen bis 10 Grad
entlang der Küsten am wärmsten im
Südwesten bei 19 Grad der Blick auf die
nächsten Tage am Freitag wird es recht
durchwachsen sein mit weiteren Schauern
und Gewittern im Osten noch halbwegs
trocken bei 11 bis 19 Grad am Samstag
wird es dann von Westen her Trockner da
gibt es dann Richtung Erzgebirge und im
Süden Regen und teils schau bei 12 bis
20 Grad und der Sonntag wird
hauptsächlich im Süden nass nach Norden
hin viel Sonne damit ein schöner Abend